[Musique]
on retrouve ce soir à notre panel
politique Michel David Christian Dufour
et Stéphanie Gramont je vous salue tous
les trois
alors évidemment l'événement poste
électoral marquant de la semaine là
c'est ce caucus de la CAQ aujourd'hui
tous les députés ceux qui ont gagné leur
élection ceux qui ont perdu aussi été
tout cela mais surtout ce qui était
frappant c'est qu'on a vu un François
Legault tout sourire détendu réellement
aujourd'hui et on a beaucoup par les
immigrations aussi comme s'il y avait
une sorte de Mont d'Or si vous avancez
vers une caméra vous allez parler
d'immigration la carte a fait élire 90
députés 60 confiance mandats et ça fait
dire à Geneviève Guilbaud que je suis un
Trudeau doit prendre acte de la volonté
du Québec mais aujourd'hui on a entendu
monsieur Trudeau pendant la période de
questions qui avait pas l'air vraiment
de prendre acte voici ce que ça a donné
on va laisser monsieur le goût et
Monsieur Trudeau se parler ils auront
des conversations on vous tiendra au
courant certainement mais moi je pense
qu'elle fédéral faut qu'il prenne il
faut qu'ils prennent acte du résultat de
l'élection au Québec et qui s'aperçoit
que c'est signal là qu'on envoie et
c'est demandé qu'on fait doivent être
pris en compte par le fédéral la réalité
c'est que le Québec dispose déjà
d'énormément de pouvoir en matière
d'immigration plus que n'importe quel
autre pays n'importe quelle autre
province la réalité monsieur le
Président c'est qu'il pourrait
accueillir bien plus d'immigrants qui le
font déjà
bon alors Michel David je commençais
avec vous ça se présente comment pour
les discussions à venir entre l'équipe
de monsieur Legault et Monsieur Trudeau
sur cette question-là ça se présente pas
bien mais il y a pas grand changement à
Monsieur Trudeau ne fait que répéter ce
qu'il avait dit depuis des mois sinon
des années et moi j'ai jamais pensé une
seule seconde que le fait de faire élire
90 députés changerait quoi que ce soit
du point de vue de Monsieur de Monsieur
Trudeau d'autant plus que le pouvoir de
négociation du Québec la dalle rapport
de force est très faible écoutez pendant
la campagne électorale monsieur Legault
a été très clair là le Québec reste dans
le Canada le Canada c'était avantageux
alors
quand même référendum sur les et on en
est pas encore là sur les nouveaux
pouvoirs en matière d'immigration le
problème de monsieur Legault c'est que
mettons qu'on fait un référendum
évidemment les gens j'imagine vont dire
oui on veut plus pouvoir puis que le
fédéral dit non alors là sur le goût
qu'est-ce qui va faire il faut
absolument qu'il y ait déjà une idée de
ce qui va faire en cas d'échec parce que
il est probable que un référendum ne
ferait pas changer monsieur Trudeau
d'idée
ça fait deux fois qu'on entend monsieur
Trudeau parler cet enjeu-là en disant il
positionne ça comme si le Québec voulait
plus d'immigrants comme s'il était à
côté de la question à chaque fois c'est
très provocateur
on voit que ça ça commence très
difficilement en fait parce que c'est
ironique en fait c'est que on prend pour
acquis qu'au Canada tout le monde veut
plus d'immigrants alors qu'on sait qu'au
Québec durant la campagne le débat porte
était plus complexe que ça c'est le
début d'une négociation cruciale qui va
être manifestement difficile je pense
que c'est normal que Monsieur Lego
s'adressait à Monsieur Trudeau dans un
premier temps mais c'est pas la fin de
l'exercice aussi c'est la société
québécoise que monsieur legouv va devoir
mobiliser dans ce dossier il va falloir
que l'appui en fait de d'autres parties
de faiseur d'opinion donc mais ça
commence pas très bien et c'est rare on
va avoir un politicien aussi arrogant
que Monsieur Trudeau c'est très arrogant
d'avoir écouté on est d'accord pour que
vous augmentiez le nombre d'immigrants
donc c'est à suivre en fait mais c'est
pas fini là et puis c'est trop important
pour qu'on commence à dire ça marche pas
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas fini
d'ailleurs en sortant son cocus
aujourd'hui il voulait donner un grand
message de confiance sentir dans un
rapport de force où il était dominant
monsieur Legault ça a donné ceci on va
l'écouter
les Québécois veulent que le
gouvernement du Québec est plus de
pouvoir l'immigration il y a personne
qui va prendre
une priorité ça devient une priorité des
je l'ai dit même dans la prochaine
campagne fédérale
la Stéphanie alors demain il veut
montrer une image de confiance et
comment s'appelle son deuxième mandat
mais en bout de ligne pensez-vous que
cette confiance là va être récompensée
par un quelconque gain
moi je comprends que monsieur Legault
bombe le thorse mais honnêtement
qu'est-ce que ça changerait de faire un
référendum
honnêtement ça ressemble un peu à ce que
l'Alberta a fait avec la Périgord nous
on n'est pas d'accord
mais enfin c'est pas c'est pas Québec
que les que le levier pour changer ça
donc Aqua bon et puis moi ce que je
dirais c'est que l'entente Canada Québec
qui régit l'immigration elle est
extrêmement payante et avantageuse quand
même pour le Québec donc ouvrir ça c'est
pas évident qu'on va être gagnant et
puis en fait cette entente là Québec
utilise même pas toutes les sommes qui
sont à sa disposition pour faire le plus
de francisation possible et il n'utilise
pas non plus tous les leviers possibles
donc moi je je pense que pour commencer
ce qui serait le plus simple au lieu de
chercher querelle ce serait d'utiliser
au maximum les moyens qu'on a à notre
disposition bon alors on voit très bien
que quand même monsieur le goût essaie
de le positionner le commettant le gros
débat le gros enjeu mais il a un autre
gros défi aussi à faire le fameux
délicat exercice de former un conseil
des ministres répartir les
responsabilités ménager les subtilités
alors notre collègue Véronique prince se
disait que l'annonce du Conseil ça
pourrait être dans la semaine du 17
octobre ça reste quand même un gros défi
on va entendre laisser monsieur LEGO
on a une belle équipe évidemment que le
plus grand défi pour les prochaines
semaines cette formée Conseil des
ministres parce qu'il y a tellement de
monde forts que ça va être des choix
déchirants
de ce que si ça complique l'exercice
bien sûr et c'est l'envers en fait de la
victoire de
cocus de 90 députés sur le coup c'est
merveilleux mais dans un deuxième temps
c'est difficile à gérer et puis très
rapidement parce que il y a constituer
un conseil des ministres tous les
députés veulent être ministre ils
trouvent tous quand les compétences pour
être ministre il va avoir moins de gens
choisis par définition
trouvent qu'ils ont les compétences pour
leur rester aussi exactement ça veut
dire que pour Monsieur Legros c'est un
gros problème mais c'est vrai que dans
les quatre prochaines années le caucus
risque de plus en plus d'être difficile
à gérer par définition la nature humaine
étant ce qu'elle est donc mais dans un
premier temps disons que c'est un beau
problème c'est quoi le défi là dedans
Michel est-ce que c'est d'éviter de
faire trop de mécontents
ils vont en faire quelques-uns mais moi
je vois pas ça comme un problème
tellement grave à écouter les transfus
ça existe là mais où est-ce qu'ils vont
aller ces gens-là ils se pensent qu'il y
a mieux quand même être au gouvernement
que dans un parti de position qui a 0
le gars qui vous la dame qui va
traverser la chambre pour aller siéger
ses conservateurs à des grosses chances
de faire un mandat et et que sa carrière
s'arrête là il y a beaucoup de gens qui
je pense vont beaucoup hésiter avant de
faire ça non je crois pas du tout
mais il va falloir gérer sur mes
contentement là écouter il y a toutes
sortes de formules moi je me souviens de
l'époque où Robert Bourassa avait lui
aussi des députations là pharaonique et
il les occupaient à des choses dont on
peut questionner l'utilité moi je me
souviens de comité sur les cantines sur
les autoroutes sur la couleur de la
margarine etc alors donc on occupe son
membre finalement il faut occuper son
monde mais mais c'est un peu comme un
camp d'entraînement de d'un cube de
hockey au début plus ordures à tous les
postes sont ouverts puis au fur et à
mesure où on commence à examiner ça il y
a peut-être pas de temps de postes parce
que là il faut tenir compte évidemment
de la parité à une femme faut tenir
compte des impératifs de la répartition
régionale etc alors on n'aura pas un
conseil des ministres où il y a la
moitié qui vont être du sang neuf il va
y avoir d'abord on connaît déjà les
incontournables de par leur compétences
respectives bon au final ça l'économie
monsieur Dubé à la santé
mais il y aura quelques quelques
exclusions on peut déjà imaginer je sais
pas moi je pense à Madame Roy par
exemple je pense qu'elle va être appelée
à
comment dire à compter les moutons sur
les banquettes de l'opposition on entend
peut-être
présidente de l'Assemblée
c'est une possibilité mais il y aura des
exclus et je pense que monsieur Legault
honnêtement ça l'empêchera pas de dormir
je comprends que c'est difficile mais
c'est le genre de gars qui est capable
de dire bon mais voilà c'est merci vous
avez rendu des bons services mais nous
sommes corrects
je me mets dans la peau d'un élu ça doit
être un moment extrêmement stressant
d'ailleurs juste aller voir fuir les
caméras aujourd'hui quand on leur posait
la question est-ce que vous dormez à
côté de votre téléphone bon vous êtes
dans quel état d'esprit écoutez il y en
a beaucoup qui voulaient pas répondre
puis qui partaient vite vite là
oui oui c'est sûr mais ça ça crée ça
crée un petit moment de stress puis
peut-être éventuellement il y aura il y
aura un peu de tiraillement mais ce
qu'il faut pas oublier dans tout ça
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
heureux problème là pour monsieur
Legault c'est comme l'envers de la
médaille de sa victoire très éclatante
de lundi mais ce qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est que tous ces gens-là les 90
députés il doit leur victoire à Monsieur
le goût parce que c'est lui le parti
c'est lui qui fait que ces gens-là ont
tous été élu alors la BSB peut-être mais
à ce point-là je pense pas que ces
gens-là vont le remettre en question
demain matin et puis bon il y aurait des
gens qui seront ministres une des bonnes
nouvelles c'est qu'il y a eu une forte
députation de femmes donc on s'attend à
ce que il y a une parité aussi au
Conseil des ministres et donc pas
seulement dans les postes là plus
secondaires mais aussi dans des postes
importants ça c'est une c'est une très
bonne nouvelle et puis donc
je pense que quand même moyen de
s'organiser j'ai pas l'impression qu'il
y aura des transmis je demain matin si
on veut occuper les gens on peut leur
confier des dossiers comme cette école
dans le dans le cas de du déploiement du
réseau Internet haute vitesse au Québec
on a confié ça à quelqu'un en disant
écoute c'est toi qui est responsable et
ça très bien fonctionné c'est un
déploiement que la CAF a bien réussi
alors peut-être que c'est un modèle
qu'on pourra suivre pour pour les quatre
prochaines années qui quatre prochaines
années qui s'en viennent il y en a une
qui assurer beaucoup l'attention
aujourd'hui c'est Geneviève Guilbaud
alors madame Guilbaud elle a toute sorte
de fonctions mais elle est entre autres
celle qui est responsable de capital
national beaucoup de spéculations sur
qui le sera avec ce nouveau mandat parce
que Madame Guilbaud elle a annoncé ses
couleurs elle est prête à passer le
flambeau mais elle veut pas que ça capte
ne veut pas que les gens pensent que
c'est parce que là de mauvaises
relations avec le maire actuel de Québec
monsieur marchand je vous propose
d'écouter avec moins de regarder aussi
sa réaction quand la question lui a été
posée et je dis regardez parce que son
visage était
quelle est relation sont difficiles avec
la mère marchand c'est parce que vous
êtes une ambitieuse qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'une ambitieuse comme vous voudrez
plus un boss comme ça non mais c'est
vrai mais d'abord sur l'après mise la
question
en tout cas c'est une opinion le mais je
suis considérais pas que c'est un fait
objectif
mais vous avez alors qu'est-ce qui fait
que je sais pas c'est basé sur quoi mais
de toute façon l'important pour nous
c'est d'être député je suis une député
de la région de Québec mais ça a rien à
voir avec une
problème de relation avec Monsieur
marchand au contraire on se parle
beaucoup depuis deux trois jours puis
des fois il y a un jeu de déclaration
des fois dans le jeu médiatique où on
peut avoir l'impression mais pas du tout
on a une très bonne relation puis lui
bien content que je sois élu en tout cas
il m'a félicité
l'adjectif forcément mais c'est vrai
quand même que il y a eu des
tiraillements le entre le maire de
Québec et puis la CAF de manière
générale on se souvient à propos du
tramway ça avait ça avait fait des
flammes et puis on avait réalisé à ce
moment-là que le maire de Québec
peut-être les mères de toutes les
grandes villes était pour devenir
finalement la vraie opposition avoir le
vraiment l'Assemblée nationale très
divisée donc ça va être intéressant de
voir qui va prendre qui va prendre la
place de Madame Guilbaud et c'est le nom
qui circule actuellement ce que vous y
croyez lui il a été élu donc en face de
Québec mais on dit qu'on pourrait
élargir ce mandat ce serait pas juste
responsable le capital national ça
serait de la peut-être comme Monsieur le
gouvernement
on a entendu ça effectivement
mais en même temps c'est quand même deux
réalités différentes là et est-ce que
est-ce qu'une seule et même personne
veut porter ces deux chapeaux là ça
reste à voir mais oui l'idée de cette
deuxième métropole là que serait la
capitale
on l'entend depuis le début de la
campagne alors ça peut être que ça met
les
save la voix vers ça
importance dans notre système pour le
Premier ministre que de pouvoir énorme
on s'entend mais il faut toujours qu'il
s'occupe du caucus quelqu'un comme
Robert Bourassa disait faut pas que tu
perdes en fait le contrôle du caucus
c'est ça doit être une priorité pour
n'importe quel premier ministre
évidemment cette semaine tout est
merveilleux là mais c'est clair que dans
les années qui vont venir pour Monsieur
logo il faut pas qu'il puisse le
2ememain je me permets de pas tout à
fait d'accord avec Michel David quand tu
disais que les tranches fût je vais vers
le Parti conservateur le stade possible
c'est improbable puis quatre ans c'est
long puis un tranchant ça devient une
superstar tout de suite là un député
derrière moi kaki ce qui est frustré qui
est frustré qui est un peu à droite qui
décide d'aller chez Eric duham il
devient une grosse vedette puis la
nature humaine est en scalée c'est pas
juste négatif c'est pas impossible ce
genre de choses surtout parce qu'il faut
pas oublier d'une chose c'est que des
résultats crève de l'élection d'un lundi
c'est que les consommateurs qui ont
quand même recueilli 13% des voix ont
pas de députés donc s'il y avait un
député ce serait pas le scandale absolu
même si c'est un transfuge mais quel
serait la vie du transmet ça serait de
voir après tout de suite Michel revenant
sur justement le qui pourrait
représenter la croisade nationale où
est-ce qu'on élargit le concept là à
faire la deuxième métropole du Québec
vous en pensez quoi oui ben d'abord je
pense que Madame Guilbaud a décidé de
laisser son poste parce que ça savait
que elle serait pas reconduite dans
cette fonction-là à la beaudire les
relations étaient pas faciles avec avec
le maire je peux sa sortie ce que vous
êtes finalement pardon elle protège un
peu sa sortie
moi je voulais partir de toute façon
oui je pense qu'il peut élargir la
capitale nationale à la couronne sud et
oui je verrai bien monsieur Drainville
pour une raison c'est que il va il va
avoir une grosse bataille sur le
troisième lien le gros dossier dans la
région pendant le deuxième mandat ça va
être ça et on l'a vu le monsieur
drinville a l'air déterminé à faire
passer ça dans la gorge de à peu près
tout le monde là chez moi que les grs
puis et Monsieur Drainville est un
batailleur alors je pense qu'il
détesterait pas être investi ce dossier
là peut-être sera-t-il même ministre des
Transports on verra ce que monsieur
Legault désirait décidera mais non je
vois pas du tout qu'on puisse interdire
à quelqu'un de la réussite de Québec
d'être responsable de l'ensemble de la
région alors on verra quel sera la
décision de monsieur Legault en bout de
ligne c'est lui qui décide on va parler
de l'Alberta et on parle d'Alberta parce
que c'est un grand moment aujourd'hui
pour cette province en ce moment le
Premier ministre c'est Jason qui est née
le démissionné il assure l'intérim
jusqu'à ce soir parce que ce soir ce
sont les membres du parti qui
choisissent le nouveau chef mais de
factobre le chef va devenir le nouveau
Premier ministre que ça aussi vous aviez
envie d'en parler de ce sujet là
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire tout ça parce que Monsieur kenny
se propose et c'est toujours un petit
peu proposé comme étant
pré-du-québec qui parle français avec
une dvdilité autonomiste aussi un petit
peu je vais vous entendre là-dessus
c'est vrai que le Québec perd un allié
en fait donc on n'a pas exploité parce
que Monsieur Jason Kenny a fait une
tournée au Québec un moment donné pressé
de convaincre les Québécois d'accepter
plus sur les les plus plains il avait
tendu la main à Monsieur Lego il parle
très très bien français comme vous
l'avez dit et il rappelait en fait
historiquement c'est arrivé à plusieurs
reprises qui avaient une conjonction
d'intérêt entre l'Alberta et le Québec
monsieur qui est né en fait c'est un
albertin mais c'est un amoureux du
Canada au fond une des choses qui
explique son échec que beaucoup de gens
prévoyaient pas parce qu'au début on
avait l'impression que tout lui
réussisse il y avait de la classe il y
avait un ministre fédéral important ça a
vraiment pas marché et ce qu'on lui
reprochait c'est de ne pas être assez
albertin il doit pas être capable
d'incarner l'aliénation Alberton parce
qu'il était trop canadien et là la
nouvelle Première ministre qui s'annonce
elle le Venise sa campagne beaucoup sur
le dos du Québec puis il faut s'attendre
que dans l'avenir là ça circule beaucoup
en albertance
du Québec c'est les Québécois qui sont
les enfants gâtés du Canada donc moi je
trouve que on perd un allié un allié au
même potentiel qu'on a pas assez
exploité je trouve que Monsieur LEGO au
sein du Canada pas assez jouer la carte
Jason Kenny parce que quelque part c'est
quelqu'un qui était très francophile en
fait donc moi ça maîtrise un peu aussi
ça démonte pour finir c'est le drapeau
politique il y a des gens dont on a
l'impression qu'ils ont tout pour
réussir ça marche pas effectivement mais
ça arrive effectivement parce que vous
avez raison c'est une étoile montante
c'est bon il rebondit sur la scène
provinciale ça va être quoi après
Stéphanie sur cette nouvelle personne
alors c'est pas fait encore on va
entendre les résultats c'est ce soir
mais effectivement la favorite c'est
Madame Smith qui a une vision d'une
province souverainiste pas la source
québécoise par exemple c'est autre chose
dans son cas mais c'est ce soustraire au
cas par cas au politique canadiennes on
le voit canadiennes qui ferait pas
l'affaire selon elle de l'Alberta les
temps vont être difficiles si c'est elle
pour Monsieur Trudeau
oui bah il est éteint était déjà
difficile pour Monsieur Trudeau en
Alberta depuis un bon bout de temps mais
ça va pas s'améliorer certainement pas
mais sur les relations avec Québec moi
je trouve ça intéressant parce que je
trouve qu'avec la liberté on a un peu
une relation amoureuse ou les deux
provinces se sont souvent alliés sur des
sur des sujets comme par exemple
l'opposition fédérale sur la Commission
des valeurs mobilières uniques parce que
il y a un peu cette nature là de pas
vouloir avoir le fédéral dans ces
baskets et puis d'autre part amour hein
il y a aussi beaucoup de sujets de
discorde notamment sur la question de
l'énergie et de la périclation donc je
moi ce que j'ai hâte de voir c'est avec
cette nouvelle
Première ministre là si elle est élue
évidemment comment est-ce qu'on va aller
plus du côté amour ou du côté amour je
pense que pour l'unité nationale ça sera
une bonne idée que on puisse s'entendre
mais malheureusement ce qu'on voit avec
les années c'est que le faussé semble
s'agrandir là
en plus d'un parti qui l'est déjà en
Alberta c'est très un grand Michel ne
reste que 10 secondes vous allez
surveiller ça vous aussi ce soir oui
puis moi je suis pas certain que les
Albertins ont bien envie de se lancer
dans l'illégalité parce que c'est ça que
propose madame madame madame Smith dire
les lois qu'on aime pas on les applique
pas alors on verra ça ça va être tranché
la prochaine campagne électorale en
Alberta alors c'était le mot de la fin
je vous remercie tous les trois d'avoir
été avec nous on aurait eu long à dire
sur l'Alberta on va les laisser choisir
leur nouveau chef ce soir puis on s'en
repart bonne soirée au revoir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI